whether the workouts are occurring at
team facilities or players working out
on their own injuries can happen and do
happen in the offseason debo Samuel
working out with teammates in Nashville
suffered a Jones fracture in his foot it
was reported yesterday confirmed by the
team Deebo Samuel took to social media
and made it clear that indeed the injury
happened and he said see you in 10 weeks
now that takes us right up against the
start of the season and it makes you
wonder what kind of shape he's in makes
you wonder whether or not the standing
complications you know how it goes in
football big cat every surgery is a
success every player is ahead of
schedule in his rehab until he's not and
it's going to bear watching that Jones
fracture in the foot can be very tricky
it's like fourth or fifth metatarsal
metatarsal metacarpal one of the two
metatarsal foot is tarsal hand is
powerful I'm having a I'm having a
flashback not the femur I'm having a
flashback to biology class but the foot
it's the metatarsal and sometimes it
just doesn't want to heal right in there
so hopefully debo Samuel gets healed up
quickly for the 49ers he was great last
year he was a god-sent for that offense
and as the season went on he got better
and better and he's one of those guys
that was in the loose conversation to
possibly be the Super Bowl MVP that's
how much of an impact he had in that
game against the Chiefs I love debo
Samuel I loved him ever since South
Carolina just because of his name is
unbelievable and he's a great player
you didn't mention though Mike you you
just talked about his surgery you didn't
mention the fact that debo Samuel said
he had perfect surgery so that kind of
makes it a little different right it's
you know there's good surgery there's
bad surgery then there's perfect surgery
so I would expect him to be back do you
think Kyle Shanahan part of him got the
news and was like well that stinks but
now I can just run the ball more and
he's just ready to keep running it and
running it and running it like now
people can't even get mad at me when I
run the ball a million times a game yeah
but at some point you are gonna come up
against the team that has figured out
how to stop that although it is a
brilliant scheme that he comes up with
with the motion and the block
when you have George kid old helps and
debo Samuel was a big piece of the
running because of his willingness to
block I didn't notice that he said it
was a perfect surgery I hope that phone
call
hope that's better than a perfect phone
call but I look at some point they got
to throw the ball again and Samuel was
becoming one of their better receivers
one of the more valuable pass catchers
he had 57 catches last year as a rookie
now they have other guys who have been
injured they're used to this guys that
they have on the roster that they can't
use jalen hurd Dante Pettis they're
going to have opportunities to work
these guys in this year Kendrick born
was a very very good receiver last year
for the San Francisco 49ers a guy who
made some big catches in the divisional
round game and look until debo Samuel is
back and that 100% the other guys have
to step up and one of the things I saw
earlier in the year after Emmanuel
Sanders left in free agency a guy that
the 49ers had given up I believe a
third-round pick to get in trade from
the Broncos during the season and he's
gone after just you know 10 11 12 games
the other receivers the younger
receivers were saying how his influence
will resonate that even if you don't
have that veteran receiver there this
year it resonates with the young guys
and they've learned how to be
professional and they've learned from
Emanuel Sanders and those fumes will
linger so maybe that'll help some of
these other guys step up but debo samuel
was expected to be a big part of that
they have branded a coup they drafted in
round one a guy they really really liked
a little more pressure on him to make an
impact right away
bottom line is it's not good high level
analysis it's not good when one of your
key players gets injured in June and is
out for 10 weeks but still it's always
better we said this about Brandon Brooks
earlier this week it's better to have it
happen now than to have it happen week
one because at least now you had a
chance to come up with a plan to react
to maybe go out and get a veteran
receiver if you need one in the early
stages of the season while debo Sandals
getting back to a hundred percent so
this is football you're gonna have
injuries and you adapt on the fly you
adjust you react and you try to make the
best decisions you can and more catches
for George skittle so 49ers will be fine
they have the best tight end in the game
yep I said it I said it best tight end
into the game yeah they did today the
49ers did draft Brenda up from Arizona
State in the first round and I would
expect that that's part of the plan
right there and it was you know it feels
like the draft is a million years ago
because who knows what time is anymore
but that was one of the deepest wide
receiver drafts we've had probably ever
and there's gonna be a lot of great wide
receivers out of there so they might
have won with their first-round pick
some facts on the Jones fracture
courtesy of producer Pete Dye mellitus I
mentioned Trent Taylor last year Taylor
had a Jones fracture during training
camp they expected him to return in six
weeks he experienced complications from
the first surgery had a second procedure
the foot became in fact that he missed
the entire seasons and Sammy Watkins had
a Jones fracture in May of 2016 it took
him two years to get fully back to
health I remember Dez Bryant dealt with
the Jones fracture this is not an easy
thing to come back from and the 49ers
can only hope that that 10-week estimate
from the perfect surgery is going to be
the right number for debo Samuel their
best play is to have a plan be a strong
Pam plan B in place and whatever they
get from debo Samuel the first half of
the season they should regard is icing
on the cake
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports